stephen mats is a much different pitcher
right now than what they saw in the past
absolutely first month of this season
this has been a steal for the blue jays
they got him from the met for three
minor leaguers and all he has done he's
won all four of his starts for the blue
jays this season the first picture
pitcher in team history
to win each of his first four starts
trey's in and we're away
and trey's on it laces that one into
left field for a lead-off single here in
the first
here comes the change and there goes the
no-hitter and in the park single for
trade turner tonight
and there's the home run club right
there five home runs between them last
night
they're they're over there flexing at
first check out my guns let me check out
my gun
ryan zimmerman fresh off his two-run
homer out to right field last night
zimmerman ground ball left side and that
one gets through
little miscommunication it looks like
there trey turner will motor to third
and the nats will take it runners at the
corners which is one out here in the
first
well if you missed it last night we told
you the story in toronto right now is
the left side of the infield i think joe
panic might have actually lost that
grounder in the sun
that can happen on the chopper folks you
can see him putting the glove up in his
face
and you see that patch of sun by stephen
mats right there maybe he lost this in
the sun
so ryan zimmerman going good the third
baseman lost the ground ball in the sun
how many times do you see that
i i can't ever remember seeing a ground
ball lost in the sun
that is wild there's a stalin castro one
ball
two strikes runners at the corners one
out strike three call
right down in the middle darling castro
just throws at home plate and takes
strike three call that's what i mean
about the compliments
the the change up compliments the
fastball because it's so good as a
hitter you've got it in the back of your
mind
then you can just buzz that fastball
right there it's in a good
a good spot down and in and now matt's
has a left hander in the box in the
field kyle schwarber ground ball this
should get him out of the
inning simian to guerrero and that'll do
it
steven matz gives up a couple of singles
the national strand of pair will go to
the bottom of the first
eric fetty will go at the blue jays
here tonight eric fetty making his fifth
start of the season his last three have
been
solid george springer is having his
first fight appearance of the season
the adrenaline is pumping right now you
know he wants to do something special
in his first regular season game for the
jays there's a drive to the alley and
right field here comes the right field
they're here
perez who makes the catchphrase so what
a way springer retired on a line drive
to right field
this is how you want to pitch to
vladimir guerrero jr right now nobody on
base
swinging a miss might have tipped it
john gomes hangs on and eric fetty has a
strikeout of vladimir guerrero jr to end
a one two three bottom of the first
and that's her hitting a major league
best 304 against left-handed pitching
this season
victor robles will improve that number
curry all the left fielder cuts it off
worlds fires it in and holds roplas
after a wide turn
three turner's getting a lot done in the
lead-off spot this season as trey
smokes one through the hole and the nats
now have two on
with nobody out here in the third prime
opportunity here
two home runs last night two singles
tonight see the leg kick
before the two-strike approach you can't
get in there a lot of speed on the bases
right now
robles and turner we'll see if davey
tries to get a little action
the one two oh it got him on the foot
josh harrison
for the second time in as many games in
this series hit by a pitch
and just like that the bases are loaded
with nobody down
would you like surprise with that hit by
pitch oh look at him hustling down to
first i love
the excitement that this guy plays the
game with he's always smiling now brian
zimmerman
zimmerman career four for five for 18
now off mats and he grounds one to the
left side and through
this will score two runs and the
nationals have a two-nothing lead here
in the third inning
ryan zimmerman for the second straight
day comes through with a big knock
said it last night oh man it's good to
see him do well
a big hit for the gnats and the base is
loaded hasn't been his best friend
throughout his career and he just made
it his good buddy right there with the
big knock two to nothing
starlin castro in now to try and keep
the line moving
castro hard ground ball up the middle
this one will
score another run josh harrison comes
around and the nats have opened the lead
up to three nothing here in the third
line
is moving two outs runners at second and
third
ground ball in the hole it's short long
throw by buchet scoop by guerrero
and they save two runs right there what
a throw by bowen what is stretched by
vladi
horrific defense on the infield and matt
gets out of the inning
you've got a guy who can knock in some
runs
cutter this time slow grounder trey's
gonna bare hand it
and what a play wow huge play by trey
turner
to come in barehand it and get grichik
at first
that's the only chance he had what a
play by trey trey singled in the first
singled in the third and came around to
score
robles will take off turner puts it in
play to center field
and this one will drop richik didn't
come in on it at full speed
robles didn't know whether to go back to
first or stay put or
advance but trey turner is now three for
three and then that's have two on
the nats are threatening in the fourth
josh harrison
josh harrison a big swing gritchik
moving back on it
at the wall and it's gone josh
harrison's second home run of the season
and the nats have busted it open here in
the fourth inning no longer a singles
party
and just like that it's six to nothing
national shift to the left side against
simeon
betty peers in has the sign rox kicks
and pitches
yeah swinging a miss that's the slower
one that's the slider
for eric fetty or the curveball i guess
regardless a good result
yeah one side of the plate to the other
like the slider there just enough
here's joel panic left-handed header
swinging a miss for strike three
eric fetty with back-to-back strikeouts
to end the fourth this guy
is cruising and the nats have a
six-nothing lead
josh bell turning around about
left-handed 2-1 pitch
cracked in the air to left field moving
back on it is the left fielder looking
up it is gone goodbye
over guriel over the wall and
straightaway left
and banged off an advertising billboard
above the wall right back onto the
playing field
there it is for josh bell an opposite
field
to run bang zoomy goes with his second
of the year rbi's four and five
and it's now the nationals eight and the
blue jays nothing
sometimes you just gotta keep it simple
right there's guria it's one high and
deep and this one's gonna go
opposite field home run for guriel
they stayed on that pitch for lourdes
that's his first home run of the season
and that is a really good sign we
we've been waiting for him to break out
also he's he's a good hitter
but he's just been off a little bit this
season
that's a good sign driving the ball the
other way
he walked his first time up on some good
takes
now gets a pitch out over the plate and
rockets his first home run of the season
maybe he's gonna start getting hot
bottom of the eighth inning a new
pitcher for the washington nationals
here's beau bashem
swinging in drive this ball has got a
chance it's gonna go off the scoreboard
for
beschette a first pitch home run beau
beshek with his sixth home run makes off
the
five of the eighth for the blue jays his
second hit of the night
he is two for four with a double and a
homer yeah a couple more extra bass hits
for bo
he was sitting all over that first pitch
he knew he was going to throw on the
first pitch strike
you know you you're down eight to one
that pitcher doesn't want to walk to
anybody he's going to throw that thing
right in there and beau was waiting for
it
got six home runs and 13 rbis now and
that's why you just think that
eventually the top of the order with
springer bushette and guerrero
are going to be a real pain in the side
of opposing pitchers
got to figure he's got to throw him a
fastball right you're up eight to two
there's two outs
number nine hit her at the plate and
there's the slider for the final out
brad hands
a perfect ninth inning picks up a k of
jansen to finish it off
and handshakes all around for davey
martinez and the boys